what is the misconception that came out
to that wide audience that is not true
that you want to clear up right now to
my audience
uh that Bobby Lee episode was edited and
they made me look like I wasn't a
comedian that can't take a joke even
though every episode they make jokes on
and the reason I walked away was
definitely not put in there
okay and that's it and I could leave
that in I guess so yeah yeah I guess and
and like they they definitely they moved
around very disrespectfully behind
closed doors they didn't that's what
entertainment is though that's every
form of entertainment isn't everyone
trying to cut certain things to tell a
certain story or click bait yeah
whatever I mean that's what you when you
get into this world of making
entertainment you gotta know that
they're going to be editing to make it
as to get as many clicks to get as many
stories to get as many comments as
possible would you share the Feister
dad's Integrity for it I mean he did an
interview with Tom Sandoval so I guess
so does that mean anything to you I
don't even know who that is yeah it
didn't mean anything to me but I got
apparently that's it yeah so he did my
point is he did an interview that did
not make him look very good and a lot of
people have perceptions of him that is
not are not true that he's a cheater or
a massage whatever it was and it's not
true and he knows that he knows that
about himself he knows who he is yeah he
knows he's been married to my mom
forever and have never has never cheated
so it doesn't bother him and he knows
that when he comes on the show I'm just
you know I'm good for and we talked
about that before this show it's about
you gotta feel good you just said it
that was your whole analogy with would
you rather have the belt or would you
rather know that so knowing who you are
and the way it is did it make for a
better show the way it was cut
that made me miserable dude that that
pulled me through a terrible
time
that wasn't that that was probably the
worst moment so as a friend not as a
business but as a friend it was
up as a business
no they they did it to
it
see it's I I it's it's basically this is
what it is man like
and I'll say this confidently the truth
always comes out who you are will come
out if you're a piece of that's
gonna come out if you're genuinely a
good human being that will come out I
don't need to go and Bash anybody I'm
very thankful for what they've done
God will show in front of everyone who I
am and who the people that try to stop
but but the truth is they didn't stop
you you have you tried to you have a
what do you mean they tried to stop you
I mean bro they even try to interfere
with my own show started making
decisions for my own show and I was like
that's where I started going hey guys
I've juggled enough for you guys and
been disrespected on this show now
you're trying to come the over here
and try to tell me how to run my own
house
I was like nah you guys
[Music]